[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
VIVIAN SONG: In
this video, we will
be going over a Goodie
Bag number two which is
about electronic transitions.
What you'll need are four LEDs--
white, blue, green, and red--
and one spectrometer.
The objectives in this video are
to understand photon absorption
and emission, apply
the Bohr Model,
and use the spectrometer
to see sample spectra.
The conceptual questions
you should keep in mind
are, how do electrons transition
to different energy levels?
And why is spectroscopy a method
of material characterization?
As a reminder,
the Bohr Model can
be used to model these
electronic transitions,
assuming that there's only
one electron in the atom.
So right now, I'm going to
draw my energy axis and three
different energy levels that
my electron can hop into.
So this is one,
and two, and three.
So let's say that our electron
starts in the ground state.
And it absorbs
some energy and can
hop to a higher energy level.
But in doing so, at this
higher energy level,
it is in a more unstable state.
Eventually, it'll want to return
to that more stable state.
And when it does so, it emits
energy in the form of a photon.
So emit photon
and absorb energy.
These different
electronic transitions
can be tracked
with this equation.
So the change in energy is equal
to minus 13.6z squared times 1
over nf squared minus
1 over ni squared.
Where z is the
atomic number, and f
is the final state
of the electron.
And i is the initial
state of the electron.
And this change in energy
is in electron force.
So remember that these
electronic transitions
are quantized since these energy
levels are not continuous,
but they're integers.
This means that the photon
that the electron emits
is going to have a certain
set of different wavelengths.
And we can see that with
this equation energy equals
hc over lambda, where energy is
equal to this change in energy.
h is Planck's constant.
c is the speed of light.
And lambda is the wavelength
of our emitted photon.
After looking at the
red and white LEDs
through the spectrometer, you
should see something like this.
Notice how for the red LED,
mostly the red and orange bands
are visible.
Whereas for the white
LED, almost all the colors
are visible.
Another thing that
you could explore
is using your spectrometer
to look at the ceiling lights
and seeing how that spectra
would differ from the spectra
that you observed
from your LEDs.
In summary, electrons
absorb and emit
photons of different wavelengths
because electronic transitions
are quantized.
By capturing this
information, the spectrometer
becomes a very useful tool for
characterizing our materials.